tenemos otra vez nuestra balanza hay una
cierta cantidad de masa del lado
izquierdo así como del lado derecho
podemos observar que nuestra balanza
está en equilibrio esta vez utilice la
letra x para denotar a cada una de
nuestras masas misteriosas y lo que
queremos saber es cuál es la masa de
cada una de ellas de las masas
misteriosas y me gustaría invitarte a
pensar qué es lo que podríamos hacer
para saber cuánta más en kilogramos
tiene cada una de estas masas
misteriosas por ejemplo si pudiéramos
hacer algo a ambos lados de la balanza o
nada más alguno de los lados te voy a
dar algunos segundos para que lo pienses
tal vez se te ocurra pensar si yo
pudiera terminar con una sola de las
masas misteriosas del lado izquierdo y
conservar el equilibrio en la balanza
entonces ése sería el valor de la masa
misteriosa y en principio la idea es
válida entonces tal vez pensaríamos
circuito dos de las masas misteriosas
a ver vamos a buscar un color apropiado
y las eliminó pero si elimino estas dos
masas y nada más dejo una sola entonces
el lado izquierdo de la balanza tendrá
menos masa será más ligero y entonces el
plato del lado izquierdo subirá y el
derecho
bajará y entonces pensarás ya entendí lo
que está pasando si yo quito algo del
lado izquierdo
tendré que quitar exactamente lo mismo
del lado derecho para mantener el
equilibrio pero si quito dos masas del
lado derecho pues no es una solución
porque no sabemos el valor de las masas
misteriosas otra idea puede ser es si yo
dejara un
tercio de lo que hay en cada uno de los
lados mantendría el equilibrio o lo que
es lo mismo multiplicar por un tercio
cada uno de los lados la masa total de
este lado es exactamente igual a la masa
total del otro lado si yo tomo un tercio
de la masa total de este lado y un
tercio de la masa total del otro lado
serían lo mismo así que dejemos un
tercio del total de lo que hay en este
lado que es equivalente a multiplicarlo
por un tercio si quito dos masas de este
lado solo me quedaré con un tercio de lo
que hay y de este lado veamos cuánto
tenemos tenemos 123456789 masas si
multiplico un tercio por nueve obtengo
tres entonces tendré que quitar estas
que están de este lado y me va a quedar
simplemente tres y con esto tengo una
tercera parte de lo que había del lado
derecho y una tercera parte de lo que
había del lado izquierdo y la balanza
continúe en equilibrio porque tenemos
la tercera parte de lo que había de cada
lado y podemos concluir que x es igual a